go on uh
let me
I have some stuff prepared like Maps
on the side in case people want to you
know see more about that
just in case
it's always good to be prepared at least
a bit
oh yeah
well I'm I'm horrible at multitasking so
yeah it's uh
it can be quite difficult for me
sometimes
like like juggling multiple screens all
over the place
uh
uh let me see yeah I think this is good
enough what an ugly thumbnail it's just
a logo
and our logos above it like when you
start incorporating other people's logos
they all have different colors and
there's no color scheme like everything
every rule of design goes out the window
also also what's up chat
yeah what's up chat
well we already have one
125 viewers damn that was fast hello
everyone we're already back again
I brought some friends uh Celtic will be
joining any time when he's ready
yeah he'll just just jump in but uh yeah
we you you were talking about demise
before so do you think it's like
Ganondorf demise uh or is it like
actually
I mean I figure it's like a Ganondorf
demise thing
right now yeah like yeah it would be
really cool if he's you know
transforming into demise and in a way I
think technically that is correct but
it's not actually demise but when you
look at that it's straight up is like a
one-to-one to demise it is it has that
like lawn flowing hair the the scaly
like arms with that red kind of glow to
them the size of the hands and the whole
robe yeah and like when you see the shot
after with Ganondorf you see how when he
raises he uh extends both his arms those
same columns are on either side so it
tells me that like that shot is before
the one with the demise like figure with
the blood moon yeah wait let me let me
get that one up real quick uh it's
pretty cool that is something uh Celtic
said as well and I I didn't notice that
but you see the plants like at the
bottom they're the same and the the two
columns are the same too yeah so it's
like he doesn't like a little
transformation thingy or something
yeah it's at least demise inspired
exactly Luan because like it doesn't
have to be actually demise but
you can't deny that it's straight up is
resembling demise you know oh yeah here
it is yeah like these plants that uh
this
these plants here at the bottom and this
column is the same in the other shot so
he does do like a a transformation or
something but yeah I mean Ganondorf has
always been kind of like demise's chosen
Champion like I think even the books say
that out of all quote-unquote demon
Kings or beings of evil Ganondorf has
the most potency
to be uh like the Incarnation of pure
hatred and evil and stuff like that
um
I got a couple of Super Chat thank you
Robbie
thank you split Bolt
Zelda's tier has the recall glyph on it
uh please discuss I need answers as to
why is she the golden light from the
delay announcement that is a good one uh
what do you think will is that uh well
so
oh sorry I'm just responsible yeah no go
go ahead go ahead so I did I did want to
check because when I when I saw it um I
was like oh I wonder if that that is
kind of like the recall
um assemble because it's kind of hard to
see so I did look at the actual symbol
and yeah it is straight up the recall
symbol it is perfect it's cut off but
you can see where the other end is
that's a part of the symbol as well so I
do wonder if like each cheer we collect
possibly through the dungeon or
something like we know that other
characters have these tiers but
it it might like mean that you also get
a new ability which
I kind of figured that the format would
be similar to like the high breath of
the wild great Plateau where you'd start
with those four basic abilities on that
first island but like obviously that's
not guaranteed so perhaps each like
dungeon you you complete or something
maybe each re each ability is on one of
these tiers and that would also mean
that if there are seven there'd be three
more abilities we don't know of yeah
surprising but um and I think Zelda lore
also pointed out that the there's a
difference between the power like recall
and the other three powers whereas it
has a rune and it glows yellow instead
of green
so there's like clearly some sort of
separation between the different powers
some are some of them are drawn from a
different Source I guess uh I also
noticed that in one of the shots uh
where you see uh sidon fighting
alongside link
uh let me look that one up
real quick
does he have a tear there or does he not
have it yet well he has it in a later
shot but in the shot where he's fighting
with link he doesn't have it out there
yeah yeah exactly so I wonder if each
dungeon you're getting like the tier for
the character or something it might be
like trying to assemble like a new Sage
yeah yeah exactly I think that's exactly
what it is because here he clearly
doesn't have it on his uh on his palm
yeah that's definitely I definitely
agree with that currently
um it just it does make sense and like
each of them may be accompanies I think
someone even mentioned that you can see
Zora's domains tail fin in the shot
somewhere like the the top of Zora's
domain I can't remember where uh this uh
thing here is uh probably yeah yeah and
you see also like in the shots where it
seems clear that like with the flying
ships there's that Hebrew storm and also
that that fight against that like Goma
like ice thing they're both taking place
in Hebrew and both of them include the
Rito quote-unquote Champion which in
this case isn't Teba it's his son it's
his son so it makes sense so it makes
sense if each person you work with each
person to recover whatever tier is there
and then maybe they get it
um I'm absolutely excited though for
this because it shows how it's not a
cutscene so like you actually will have
uh these Side characters who hopefully
will contribute and I mean given the
fact that sidon did you know whack
um
uh
the robot and it died with that hit yeah
obviously they're going to be able to
it's not just like an aesthetic thing
where like you see you know people
fighting in the background of like any
game but they don't actually do damage
so it's very exciting
someone says you said you'd stop today
yeah but I had an Insight plus I said
you had an activity this is the activity
this is this is the activity no uh my my
dog is not doing too well he's uh being
very he's very stressed out he has
hormone problems so we're gonna have to
take him to the vet next week but we
have to do so what was his name again uh
dino
uh yeah thoughts and prayers for Dino
everyone well he's healthy but he's just
very like his hormones are going nuts so
he's constantly stressed out in whining
and I guess he wants to find a mate
he's a teenager now so
but yeah like here clearly sidon doesn't
have the tier on his uh on his arm but
in the later shot where you see all the
Champions together which uh I never
noticed unobo is also there but oh yeah
here it is wait I just had it
like here he does have it honestly you
can see unovo's weapon right or like at
least yeah because I was I was wondering
there's no official art for him I wonder
if the Goron Champion's gonna be
entirely new character
yeah because
they obviously it would make sense to
show the current ones because you know
we know the other two which were like
the successor Champions but then the
third one it was a new Champion but it
was already a character we know so the
fact that there's no official art of the
fourth makes me wonder if the Goron will
be just an entirely new character
because it would also add just variety
true
yeah true
and I mean uh I think taba was supposed
to be already pretty old and Rito don't
live very long in general compared to
the other races Kevin's dead Dev is dead
or he's like the videos
definitely the other like just stop you
were wrong about Zelda that was still
alive
well we'll see maybe he's just uh the
clan leader now he's sitting in that
rocking chair that the the owl guy is
sitting in but yeah you could you can
clearly see he has the tear here here he
doesn't have the tier so I guess one of
the goals in the game is to go get those
tiers and present them to the new Sage
that are gonna replace the other sages
because there's also a shot where you
can see
that goat figure guy uh
who talks to Zelda too
yeah this this guy you can see a Talon
here which is clearly a redo the this
that figure on the on the left of him
or on his right technically that's a
that's a Rito and I guess this is a
different race
looks more a human
so yeah I never noticed that I just
figured there were more of those
creatures in the background this is this
is clearly like a Talon like a redo
Talent so I guess there was a group of
sages before
who stopped Ganondorf and maybe that's
how he got sealed in the first place
because this guy do you think do you
think this bit then maybe is like a past
yeah cutscene or something I think so
hmm yeah I think that might be the case
uh because we also have that weird case
where like the great Plateau walls are
like different
so there there's clearly something in
the game that calls back to an old event
that took place a long time ago
right yeah
so I guess there was like maybe a group
of sages before this who sealed Gannon
like collectively and now there's the
these new sages have to be recruited
which obviously sidon is a great uh is a
great choice
that riju is a lot older now so she's a
good choice too
don't know about unovo but
hey it almost just you know though yeah
well also actually also uh another
reason tab I might just stop it is like
he did get injured during the meadow
thing I'm not sure if that's a permanent
injury but like oh yeah that's true
yeah yeah that's true I know that I know
that Hearth that guy like got seriously
injured uh
yeah the old girl yeah I never yeah
that's a good point though I never I
never thought of the fact that maybe
they're just individual different
figures they could they could be in more
of the ancient sages of the past
yeah I think there was a group of sages
before them
just like how there were Champions
before
the ones that uh piloted the the Divine
beasts
uh hyrule's Beetle Supply yeah that
definitely does look like a closed eye
on the similar to the mural figure also
there are particles of like malice in
the background
so yeah I feel like it further than I
suggest that they're like maybe up
against Ganondorf right now like in the
past or something past memory cutscene
whatever and this guy looks pretty
roughed up too he's all like uh it's
like suit on his uh on his face and then
on his ears uh chip monkey says for the
voiceover implies
a shot before this are recruitable
characters
oh as in like the side on and stuff are
recruitable characters
yeah I guess there's gonna be like a
situation similar to breath of the wild
where like when you enter the Divine
beasts you always had this little
gameplay segment with one of the new
Champions except this time maybe they
will have a little bit of a bigger role
um
Alexander Fraser says you're
overthinking it they're totally so nice
and their dragon Dino creatures
yeah I guess so I mean I mean hey yeah
there probably is it probably is related
to the the zonai stuff well speaking of
this uh Zone I since I have you on
anyway I mean come on uh we have to at
least address the Zone I uh I was
talking to Celtic about that is do you
think the zonai will actually be in the
game or is it going to be like a Castle
in the Sky type of deal where the only
thing left of them is this technology
and stuff and the actual Zone I are long
gone maybe wiped out by Ganondorf in one
of those calamities that we see on the
mural and stuff
um
I'm really not sure
I don't know
I think there might be a chance that we
don't actually see a living well well
I'm pretty sure that the reason they
built robots was because they were sure
they wouldn't be around
um
and they needed like something to stay
behind
but
I I'm really not I don't I don't have
like a
draw an opinion on that I'm sort of just
like on the fence about it whether we'll
actually see some or not again like the
person on the mural could be like
technically what the Zone like the
person here yeah
uh it could be like what the zonai
are
yeah it's not it's funny because I was
um
I was joking about uh we finally saw our
first zonai swirl in this trailer oh in
The Labyrinth yeah hey yeah it's like
hey finally they don't really show
anything but it
floating after all because he's using
the paraglide in there but they don't
show the bottom so we don't know for
sure
yeah yeah it might be flying it's still
like the shot with high flow Hebrew maze
is still on the ground
um so I have a feeling the mazes
probably don't rise up and there's just
like a maze equivalent in the floating
Above The Mazes and it's like somehow
connected or something
yeah could be
um wait do I have a picture of the uh
because he does use it I mean obviously
the we know for sure now that the mazes
will have some sort of secondary purpose
now
yeah and they and and they're definitely
definitely were like they definitely did
originate from the Zona because one idea
that I had suggested in the far past is
because was that it was like a
recreation made by the chica
because I compared it to some past some
other architecture and this world found
on the animal motifs but it seems pretty
clear that that the zonai were the ones
to build these mazes yeah
at this point I'm uh like it was just a
difference in architecture that kind of
threw people off but uh oh by the way
this text uh around the pedestal has
been successfully translated to
transport
I think it says Tower uh either these
words here or these ones here this one
says transport but I think the letters
no I think that one's transport one two
t-r-a-n
[Music]
yeah but the the ones uh around this
ring yeah I'm pretty sure that's
transport someone said aside the
outside's the tower there that one on
the on the rim that one's Tower yeah
yeah that's Tower tower Tower just in a
it's funny I completely I completely
missed out those chica on the wall I was
just focused on the platform so yeah
that pretty much confirms that he's
going up to those Towers he even has
that spool of wire with him and he does
have a chica slate thing he has a new
Chica slate yeah I'm not sure how
relevant it will be to like gameplay
stuff it might just be something where
he only like hooks it up to like the
towers to go up or something because it
is attached to that spool of wire
yeah and in the other trailer one of the
one of the Guardian hands also is caring
yeah some sort of spool thingy uh let's
see I think I had one more
oh yeah uh thanks again Chief monkey
in general thank you for the for the
super chats really really awesome
but yeah these are probably going up to
the towers and but we don't know what
their purpose is
but I guess the sheika built new towers
in the meantime because this has to be
at least a few years after the fact like
after breath of the Wild
seeing read you
considerably older now and yeah
yeah
hopefully Celtic will be here later it's
just
yeah you know him he's busy with stuff
oh he did say I assume he did agree to
join that right he says he's ready uh oh
cool
we oh wait
I invited you to the call
to see it
yeah you should be here any moment now I
know he's going to be working on his
analysis video so he won't stick around
for very long
yeah we
he's asking if we're live yeah
we are live
oh yeah okay says cool one sec so he'll
he'll be here any moment
it's gonna be awesome
uh Mega Man t 125.
imagine if the game had gotcha or DLC to
unlock rare special I mean it has a
gumball machine oh yeah yeah
the Gumball the orbs in the gumball
machine they look like the orbs in those
bubbles
yeah and Link
and uh the we've seen one of those on
the islands and it had a shop icon so
it's it has something to do with a shop
I don't think there's gonna be gacha
elements though that's not really a
Zelda thing to do I I was joking on uh
Twitter with I think Philly beats you uh
like imagine getting a five-star weapon
in Zelda but it breaks
well I'm sure they're gonna We Know
weapon durability is gonna be back but
this uh this time with the fuse ability
it's gonna be not as annoying look who's
here
hey how's it going what have we done
hey have you stopped shaking yet
I'm still shaking how about you that's
crazy
it definitely lived up to the
expectation set for the 2017 trailer
that's for sure yeah yeah because they
said at least three minutes and we know
the Nintendo that means like anywhere
from three to four and I think it was
about as long pretty much about as long
as the the big 2017 trailer for breath
of the wild compared compared to what
we've been given in the past that was
like a huge oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
do you think there's still people saying
it's 70 DLC don't you think that's dead
now we're still gonna say that because
some of them no matter
no matter what you say they're just
gonna be stubborn and some of them just
want to troll but yeah
man that's crazy though someone like I I
don't know if you saw but someone like
mentioned like in a Twitter thing mark
my words this is gonna be no nothing
more than DLC you know they haven't
they're not gonna show anything ah yeah
and then and then I quote repeated it
saying your words have been marked today
not only did was the the comment deleted
but they just deleted their whole
Twitter I mean yeah I'd have done the
same I'd have done this there's no other
option oh man yeah it's great so what
did you think well I've talked I've
talked to Don a bit about this trailer
uh just after it dropped but uh what are
your opinions I assume good I'm not
gonna you know underground
underground underground right yeah
unfortunately I doubt Zelda will be
playable at all though which sucks
because that kind of was hoping it's the
kind of thing we would have seen in this
trailer unless it's gonna be some kind
of big twist later on in the game but
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
because that that footage that we saw
with with the weird glowing trees and
from the previous trailer I thought that
was probably gonna be like her gameplay
session uh section but now we've seen
Link in that area too you can see the
glowing uh trees in the background too
yeah exactly in the in the shop with all
the the Goron Minecarts and everything
yeah it actually just played like you
can see it here uh
the glowing tree
yeah so yeah
but how awesome is it that has to be
inside Death Mountain right because you
can see the Goron logo on the Minecarts
yeah so when I first saw that I assumed
that the whole area was going to be a
kind of abandoned Goron area like uh
Goron mines in Twilight Princess that
kind of thing but then we get zonai
constructs down there which means
obviously there's a zonai link and all
the a lot of the architecture we've seen
underground in this trailer does seem
zonai architecture yeah so I don't know
it seems they went underground as well
as to the skies which is is so
interesting what could the Zona maybe be
a bit like the Chica who you know even
in breath wild they had like shrines and
stuff in ancient ruins from other people
so maybe the Zone I also had that they
they cooperated with the gorons or
something or
yeah I could see that being the case
because we see even just the sky islands
now we see sky islands that seem to
resemble Zora architecture rather than
zonai yeah so obviously it's not just
the zonai that we're building in the sky
yeah
so what is what what do you guys say
we're going what what do you guys think
of the general like is this gonna be way
more story uh heavy or is it gonna be
just like the 2017 trailer where it's
like these are pretty much all the kids
it's gonna be more story heavy yeah
I think it definitely seems that way
like breath of the wild was the
introduction to this kind of game and
like this new open-air Zelda that was
breath of Wild's job was to kind of
introduce that new type of game but now
we know how breath of the wild works we
know everything about that sort of game
it's time to take that world and you
know put a proper Zelda story in proper
Zelda dungeons in it which is what
everyone's been saying since breath of
the wild came out so for six years now
and it looks like this is actually what
they've done it looks like they've
listened and been like okay here's your
Zelda game in breath of the Wild's world
and I I really like over it I really
want that Rising structure to be
arbitrus grounds but it's not in the
right location wait you guys didn't
remember I haven't lined it up yet is it
not from what I've seen arbiter's
grounds has more like
uh like man-made pillars coming from the
sand X okay I think
somewhere else aren't these the ominous
ground right uh grounds right here you
can see the archway
uh I I don't know like I haven't I
haven't gone and checked myself but I
saw a Twitter post that apparently
showed arbiter's ground location so I'm
not I'm not too sure
but uh I hope it's arbiter's grounds
though because that would be amazing it
would make so much sense well it could
still be arbitous grounds because the
the Arby's grounds we saw in breath of
the wild was just like the archway at
the beginning
kind of looks similar like the one in
Twilight Princess but that one is that's
not the actual structure itself
that's like I already just mentioned
that there was sand sinking in the
Arbiters grounds and if I recall that
place does have the Arbiters ground
structures if you like try to find the
sinking sand shot I think it's after
this
this yeah the sinking it's before the
underground Cavern bit uh yeah the uh
the sinkholes that I think that's the
East Barons which is slightly further
east than the arbiter's grounds in
breath of the wild but either way the
structure we see rising out of the sand
yeah doesn't resemble the Arctic grounds
as we know from Twilight Princess which
is a sort of yeah
yeah those that's that's those are the
type of structures that are found in
Arbiters grounds those those pillars I
believe yeah yeah these are the the it
does look it does look different though
the overall placement of everything
yeah but these are definitely the East
Barons this is where Vana Boris
approximately would be like circling
like around this area I think the the
seven heroines are like behind this dust
cloud right here
uh but as for the other shot I'm pretty
sure that it is close to the to the to
the our business grounds where we see
that thing rising up
uh did you notice did you notice in that
sinking sand shot that Shrine has like a
green glow by like what might be the
entrance to it yeah yeah they apparently
they do have some sort of entrance yeah
it might just be like where uh link like
the paddling goes to when he teleports
to them assuming they're shrines or you
know it could be a puzzle replacement
where he enters there yeah yeah
but I'm pretty sure this here right here
this part this is the arbitus grounds
and this is the Oasis because it has
like a pool of water on it which does
match
so it's about in between there which if
I would grab the map real quick
that's uh
let me see
yeah so here's the Oasis which has that
water
and here's the obvious so it's like
approximately like in between the two
like around here or something right
where it's rising up which could still
be connected to the arborist grounds we
don't know of course uh
but I mean it's it it's clearly some
sort of dungeon that's rising up it's
way too big to be a shrine or anything
else
I wonder if the the other the first shot
we get of the underground which is after
the sinkholes
uh you can see like a wall in the
background I wonder if that means link
is already in a like dungeon or if he
was walking towards a dungeon that was
Underground
keep going to the next shot yeah this
one yeah because in the background it
looks like there are walls I'm not sure
if that's
the
if that's like related to a building
that he'll enter for like a dungeon or
if it's just random architecture stuff
this looks like the same area where he's
writing the minecart because you can see
the rails here
so this I think they only show the
inside of one dungeon so far which is
great because I want to be surprised as
much as possible
yeah and if we see a Goron dungeon it's
a safe bet to assume that we'll get a
Rito Gerudo
um like other race dungeons as well
which yeah it's going to be huge yeah I
wonder I wonder if like the sorry I
wonder if the the Death Mountain if
maybe like uh we know that obviously
malice is coming from it but I wonder if
like the lavender Mountain where like
we'll recede and then that'll like
reveal something in there
it takes us here
if we assume that the malice holes that
are covering Hyrule if we assume that
they're designed so that you Skydive
down into them which definitely seems
like the case then what if you Skydive
into the summit of Death Mountain
to access the Goron dungeon
yeah that would that would make sense
I mean the the malice has to be up there
on the summit for a reason right like
some sort of yeah blockade that you have
to figure out how to get through
yeah because we can see it affects the
whole Mountain there's that clip uh of
uh link fighting it could be a Goron
there's something rolling at him in a
cave either way yeah the whole cave is
kind of lit up with purple light which
shows you know malice is quite deeply
affecting the entirety of Death Mountain
yeah
for sure uh which one is that that's not
it
uh also this also kind of looks like a
dungeon maybe but one thing it also kind
of reminded me of was that the whole
whether I saw someone that you guys on
Twitter mentioned that it does look like
the same thing the the whole inside the
yiga clan Hideout which
uh is
apparently also Zone I made if it is the
same place of course oh no conspiracy
I was working on a video on like the
biggest mysteries in breath of the wild
that could be solved by the sequel and I
was just I just uh started on the yiga
hole part
and uh those stones and stuff that you
see like on the top of the the hole
because they kind of like decorated it
on the outside
yeah uh those are for sure Gerudo made
so it's a part of an ancient Gerudo like
excavation side
mm-hmm
that's interesting because the whole
Giga Clan Hideout was obviously Gerudo
in the beginning yeah but it's
interesting that the hole itself was
there at the same time the Gerudo
occupied the area I didn't know that
yeah oh uh Devin Denman says we know
Zelda cried a little bit after seeing
glioc
yeah it does yeah I can't lie yeah
Justin says did anyone notice in the
first
violin notes oh the first violin notes
match the beginning Melody of age of
calamities map theme really
there were a lot of references in the
trailer musical references I thought it
sounded more like Lord of the Rings to
be honest I said the exact same thing it
starts like
and I was like already in my head like
my dear Gandalf
but it uh yeah that was a great
reference did you find it interesting
that Ganondorf
has one of those tiers and it looks like
he's using the tears power
yes on his on his crown because we're
all about the Triforce right and it's
like he has he totally has a tear
yeah I didn't see it in the trailer
itself uh because neither the light
people people kept mentioning that and
it was just the quality it's like I
don't know I can't really see it but
then I saw images being shared I'm like
oh oh damn that that's right up a tear
that is straight up a tier which they
changed because it did not look like
that in the 2019 trailer it was just so
they changed they changed a lot of
things like when Zelda's falling in that
Chasm now she has a glow yeah they were
very smart they they kept things out on
purpose yeah yeah for sure
I refuse to think that all of it was
just oh last minute you know like oh
yeah let's change it no they
purposefully were like yeah I think it's
a combination between just you know them
figuring out what the story said because
obviously they didn't plan out
everything from the start they just knew
like something's gonna go down with
Link's arm ganondorf's gonna go is is
gonna go Haywire he's gonna be back they
plan stuff out and then watched some
Theory videos for a couple months and
then we're like yeah let's do let's go
with that let's go with this that you
made the Zone I happen my friend
I don't know about that
I do think I do think though they
definitely did take inspiration from
some theories I I definitely uh believe
that to some extent they have uh done
that but yeah because they do listen uh
that's been pretty obvious like Fuji
Rashi even said like oh I read that
people really want to be able to pet
dogs and stuff so yeah
I'm upset that wasn't in the trailer
that was on the top of my list for
things I wanted to see and we saw a dog
too during the gameplay demonstration
and during the previous teaser you can
also see a dog they're just teasing us
at this point
I need to be able to pet the dogs
I think he's so cool I love that like
shark fish thing that like
this one what'd you think of that it
looks it it looks kind of like the
corrupted nadra but it's it's not yeah
it has the same color scheme yeah it
also kind of looks like it's like a pool
of like I I assume obviously malice but
uh like you said it is a bit of a
different colors came with the nadra but
it kind of looks like it is just like a
pool of malice that just like
forms into like a shark exactly and then
like Dives out and then it turns back
into like maybe malice or something like
it just looks differently it's not
actually a shark let me look at that
later on later on there's the shot of
link and side on fighting a construct
and you see in the background these kind
of jets of like black malice being
thrown into the air and I don't know
what they are but they could end up as
those sharks I think it's the same color
let me check if I can see that
it's yeah a little bit further on from
here I think yeah it's after the because
they have like two breaks in the trailer
yeah I think this is also we were
talking about that before uh
like that this and the moment after that
this this is clearly an edit
where it's like one is underground
because you can see the Rocks it's a
sneaky cut it's a sneaky cut because
here you can see the ceiling uh
let me see real quick I I saw someone
talking about spamming did someone oh no
it's gone I guess uh
rendo the tear piece is real yeah for
sure uh thank you by the way
uh deep Pascal
have I missed the demise Ganondorf
discussion uh we we can get into that
again because that's for me that's one
of the most briefly we just briefly
talked about it but that was before
Celtic joined the Stream So we we can
get back to that but uh let's quickly go
to that part that you were mentioning at
uh
you you said something about malice
yes
um I think that's a little bit it's past
here I think it's one of the Final Shots
there he is
let's get out yeah
yeah is it the next one no yeah uh
is it this one
yeah there we go oh this one yeah you
see you see in the background there's
something throwing up big kind of
yeah I saw it in the background on like
sort of the left side yeah which is the
same color and the same kind of material
as the sharks
[Music]
not this shot right not the one this
shot yeah on the construct yeah yeah
yeah but when he's fighting the
construct yeah yeah
I don't see
where is where is like malice being
thrown up far in the background on the
left kind of directly behind the
construct at the start of the clip
you see those kind of weird wispy black
things in the box frame my frame
um yeah you might be able to see it I'm
going
um again also this sword is nice this
new sword yeah I think it's used to that
uh Horn of that she could call or that
construct official art do you mean this
here
yes Blacklist yeah yeah yeah yeah keeps
watching watching there's more of it I
think there's more it kind of yeah it
comes out like a fountain
oh yeah now I see it like it's flinging
these yeah so I wonder if what become
the sharks or other enemies or something
along those lines it could definitely be
yeah because they seem like to be uh
like they are able to disappear into the
floor or something like almost like it's
a liquid
yeah yeah and they really resembled the
the shots of malice that come out of the
blood moon and um from clam together in
breath of the wild when he corrupts the
Divine beasts and stuff they look like
the missiles of of malice it might it
might also just be like a monster
spawner you can go destroy or something
yeah either way it does look like it's
spotting some sort of enemy yeah
I I also really like the zero gravity
stuff yeah yeah yeah because I think
that's the same idea as what's causing
water to form those spheres those little
bubbles of water yes in this in the
center of the bubbles of water there's a
little green zone I
about this it looks like the orbs I'm at
the Spencer machine thing
oh yeah yeah yeah
it looks very similar to the dispenser
thingy yeah oh actually it's very
beginning of the trailer I think that
both the shots are pretty close by it
was the first one yeah so you think
these bubbles are related they look
pretty similar to the um when when you
look at the middle orb just
let me check uh that's like a little bit
later
though the the
um the orb machines after that shot
is it after the demise shot
no it's shortly after link jumps in the
bubble well yeah technically after you
oh it's after he jumps into the bubble
uh yeah you were at the shop before when
you jumped in the bubble
it's before this right like after the
rocket or something
gosh I don't have this trailer memorized
yet like so no yeah this one is packed
yeah
150 someone says 150.
no that's uh
that's Zelda just keep keep scrolling
back it's before that
oh it's before
yeah it's before the Zelda shot
oh this is the only tough part
yeah
yeah trying to pinpoint I should use
should have oh yeah the here it is
so it's right before this or right after
yeah so so that so you can see that orb
in the sh in in the shot now uh continue
forward oh these orbs here
they make me it just makes me think of
like the way they look hmm I don't know
if they're related they look a bit
different to me but
uh I was talking to uh Celtic before
like off stream
these bubbles
link has like a new animation when he's
underwater
where he does this thing and this same
animation also plays when he Dives on
the water
in the gameplay demonstration so I guess
I mean the fact that it can go inside
these bubbles means that there is like
some sort of underwater because he's not
just gonna pop out immediately which was
the case with breath while you couldn't
even stay underwater I don't even know
if you had an animation for that I don't
think you did because you pointed out to
me that this animation
we can see it somewhere else in tears of
the Kingdom
yeah in the uh in the gameplay
demonstration when he falls down from
the island he lands in the water and you
can see him doing this same thing where
he like puts his arms like out and he
starts like kicking his feet
that's the same animation
yeah so right do you do you want to
cover this demise thing in a second
because okay there's a lot of comments
about demands
oh yeah well what's your opinion of it
so there's obviously the shot about
halfway through the trailer uh
it looks a lot like demise uh and not
like Ganondorf as we see him later on
but um I was talking to monster mice
earlier and I don't think it's demise at
least I don't think it's demise in the
way that you'd expect in that he's
another character separate to Ganondorf
that maybe he gets released when this uh
Master Sword breaks or maybe he you know
has traveled through time to end up in
tears of the Kingdom I don't think it's
going to be any of that I think what
we're seeing here with this demise
figure is still Ganondorf but in a
different form yeah because if you have
a look in the shot of I'm gonna keep
calling him demise just for you know
yeah yeah I mean demise yeah I suppose
they're quite similar but if you look at
that shot the one if you go back a
couple of frames just where the camera
is a little bit backwards it's not
zoomed in as much yeah this pillow and
the flowers and stuff yeah exactly yeah
the flowers they match the exact same
location where Gandalf is yeah I was
literally talking to uh don about that
as well yeah
it's the same it's it's Ganondorf a few
seconds after he does his whole Don't
Look Away Revival of a king thing yes
exactly so I think he calls the Blood
Moon this Uber blood moon that we've
been seeing in tears of the kingdom and
then I think he takes on whatever this
form is and obviously design wise it
does resemble demise but that that's to
be expected because Ganondorf is in many
ways the manifestation of demise's
hatred yeah but it's still Ganondorf but
you know maybe there is it could be like
a demise form or something but it is
still Ganondorf yeah I'd say it's even
similar I'd say it's something even more
Sinister than Ganondorf it's like
Ganondorf Awakening his like embracing
his full demise the the mice Within
exactly which would be nuts because he's
like he's like it's demise in time well
that would be such a great character uh
moment for him too because before it
almost some sometimes felt like uh
Ganondorf was kind of a a like an
unfortunate victim of demise's curse
like he has no choice but to be evil
because especially in Wind Waker
especially in Wind Waker but now it kind
of shows that no he has control over he
might even have some sort of connection
with the mice that he's aware of and can
conjure up now
yeah
and he has and he has a horn yeah he has
a little horn right here he's got a horn
which is similar to the character we see
talking to Zelda the one who we're
assuming sealed Ganondorf in the first
place they're both yeah holistic forms
yeah they're like two pairs of horns
yeah yeah Chief monkey is the one who
said that thank you by the way for the
five pounds really awesome and there was
one more from
uh
Osho
uh do you all think tears of the Kingdom
will answer the seven heroines mystery
and the eighth heroine I think so yeah I
think that is one of the Mysteries that
we will see solved in this game
yeah
I know right that's that's like the most
the weirdest is it why is it there
there's no point there's not even a
cross there there's nothing there's just
like an undead Ambush at night and
that's it it's just a troll and it's
named after a character that doesn't
even have anything to do with it yeah
like it's right next to you you would
expect something to be named after my
car like inside the forest not like
right outside which is like a place of
death
maybe that's just maybe that's just the
island where all the dead people who got
lost in the woods go to I don't know I
saw I saw something I saw a couple
comments when I was doing my stream and
I also saw one of the comments here but
as link is ascending the elevator it
does kind of sound like they're saying
the future
yeah like if you listen to it it does
sound very similar to them saying the
future really yeah wait listen to it no
uh in the meantime
thank you so much once again uh could
demise become Ganondorf the voice actor
seems to change
the yell at 302 from three minutes two
seconds no longer sounds like Matt
Mercer
uh uh not too sure about that because
I'm not too familiar with his voice
because we don't we haven't heard a lot
of of him but is it is that the part
where that's like right when he goes up
the the tower right where you hear that
plays right then so play before at the
hatano uh Fort hatano and then oh I was
just there yeah
yeah it does
[Laughter]
it does it literally
but to be fair this could be uh that
thing that we had a whole video yeah
yeah what was it again
the Monda green effect yeah yeah that's
it yeah that's it what was it help us
please or save us please help us help us
please help us please it did kind of
sound like a whisper that was added into
the the song but the one that we mainly
covered was uh like the the one where
they're they're singing like please go
find my body yeah
yeah that one was clearly among the
green effect because the help us please
can also be monogreen could be like when
I listened to it it did sound like it
was like a separate track that was added
into the actual chanting as like a
Whispers but you know as anyone played
this the the trailer the sound track
backwards I'm sure I'm sure there's like
10 videos of it already on YouTube
probably because
yeah the future
it is funny
you know you know everyone that that's
hoping for like time travel so they're
like what did they say future in the
future
well there is already a lot of talk
about time travel once again because
there is like there's always like please
find me it's like what
well the one where she's like please
find me I I thought it was just there's
gonna be like two different zeldas one
that fell down and like the one that we
see is like her spirit
hmm
like her spirit and body get separated
when she quote unquote dies
that's what I thought initially I was
also very interested in the fact that
the figure talking to Zelda says that
link is the last line of defense
I I just find I don't know what it says
in the I know a quest with Aaron I
think posted some of the Japanese I
gotta take a look at it but like last
line of defense
I don't know it sounds it sounds like
they they had like a plan that they were
they are currently working on at tears
of the kingdom and like link was meant
to be like if things went wrong he would
be the last hope
so that's also a thing where I'm like I
don't know I don't know time travel like
where are they are they doing something
with Ganondorf and you know well in in
the case of
like obviously there could be time
travel I'm not ruling it out
but so far all like everything in Hyrule
still looks like it was like it was in
breath of the wild like you can still
see certain ruins that shouldn't be
there if it was like far in the past
like the ruins of London Ranch and and
other places I call a citadel shouldn't
be there probably in that case yeah but
maybe like pot maybe the past is like
specifically related to like story
cutscene stuff exactly uh that's what my
my mind immediately when exactly yeah
that's how I think it will be handled
definitely yeah it's like yeah I don't
think it's memory sequences or something
yeah I don't think it's a gameplay thing
where like I don't know that's
I would quite like it if we I don't know
I could see it being memories again but
I I'm not sure if I'd like it being
memories again you know I'd like
maybe if we could play through some of
the memories or have something a bit
more to interact with rather than just
find a glowing spot on the map watch a
video
it's and Monica just post sorry Monica
just mentioned a comment that I I
haven't brought up yet or we haven't
brought up yet and it's true like
there's a shot where the throw rooms
perfectly okay like what you're telling
me they restored the area we're claiming
to get like link thought it just if if
Castle town still ruined I I doubt they
they would have restored uh the castle
and there's also that spark it feels
like other worldly that links there so
it's like is he is he like in some other
like is this actually Hyrule like why is
he standing in a completely fine Hyrule
castle and also there is a shot where
link goes for the master sword in korok
forest and his hands are fine they're
not ruined yeah that all speaks Pat
previous before his arm gets messed up
like it's just speaking of this master
short the master sword shot sorry I
thought originally and when I was
talking to monster Mayers earlier I said
I think originally I thought this was at
the very start of the game like link
maybe retires the master sword after
breath of the wild then has to go
underground with Zelda so he picks the
master sword back up and then it gets
destroyed by Ganondorf but
if you look in the background is that a
green spiral like a spiral Stern or am I
just
exactly that one yeah near the core Rock
I'm not too sure
does it move as the clip plays or is it
no is it just no it doesn't I don't know
it's probably just leaves then I think
it's something the Clorox holding then I
do I do still think it could be like the
start of the game I think it's probably
the start of the game then he probably
would have like put the master sword
back and then he's going yeah I don't
know it's kind of it
uh it's kind of
weird to think that he's gonna briefly
go to the korok forest and then
that'll be like the introduction but you
know it it's the kind of thing you
didn't think we'd have to see really
isn't it like you just kind of start him
with the master sword and yeah
why do we have to go here and again is
our his arms are fine so well maybe we
don't actually go here and it's just
because I can imagine they will give us
sort of like Exposition at the beginning
like what happened like a memory yeah
yeah well just an opening cutscene that
happens because obviously it's not just
gonna start with link on the islands uh
there they have to explain what happened
in the years since breath of the wild
unless it's done like breath of the wild
and links and amnesiac again and at the
end of the new Sky Island Plateau he
gets a long extended memory like the
king Rome cutscene
that could also be how they do it I
don't know
could just be
a little ketchup
like uh after the Calamity we started
rebuilding Hyrule but soon words of a
new evil started spreading blah blind
you see him pulling the master sweat and
they go on their underground Exposition
and because the first gameplay we it's
almost certain that that will be in the
sky because the Japanese website does
say like it's the first place you will
be exploring or something like that I
don't know the exact wording but it says
something like that but obviously they
have to explain what happened before all
of this not just with the whole uh Zelda
falling down but even before that
because this has to take place at least
a few years after breath of the wild
given reduce age yeah yeah that's about
time to rebuild some areas as well it
looks like yeah so I just checked of
course with Aaron's thing with the
Japanese and apparently the bit where I
mentioned last line of defense it says
uh Zelda the night you mentioned who
wields the demon-propelling sword let's
entrust everything to him to link
so yeah
it seems less it seems less like uh oh
we had this plan
and you know oh it failed so we're gonna
we're gonna deal we're gonna let link
handle it let me quickly catch up thank
you hero for the gift and membership uh
ninja black hand demadorf has risen yeah
a guru guru just uh
places a few music notes yeah the music
is by the way the music is fire
this is a oh it's so good I did not
expect it it really elevates a trailer
like this if you have good music
yeah just after
um the figure says you know uh Link's
our last line of defense or whatever he
says the music that hits in at that bit
as link rides on the stone uh Stone
glider is nuts it's so good it's so good
it's amazing and Nathan uh Nathan delowe
says my question uh is this a new Ganon
uh me and my wife think it is yeah we
were talking about that off stream
before I don't think they're gonna
really explain where this new Ganon Nerf
comes from if it's like another
reincarnation because obviously you can
just reincarnate apparently according to
four Swords Adventures uh but he has
rounded ears which he hasn't had since
uh Ocarina of Time
so yeah I'm inclined to believe that
it's just it's so long after the fact
like oh after all the other games there
could easily just have been a new
incarnation of
uh of him
so
we that we might might not even get
answers when it comes to how it connects
to the old timeline maybe they just want
to give that a rest at this point
uh Chipmunks I think that's the way
they'll handle it yeah absolutely yeah I
think it's the safest bet
just let people speculate you know
yeah and it's the way breath of the wild
handled pretty much all old Zelda law is
just you know shelve it all in the era
of myth and just say things like that
timeline placement yeah yeah I'm no
expert but I have a feeling tears of the
Kingdom takes place wait for it after
breath of the wild
that's ridiculous I know I'm I'm so
sorry
you know I was wrong with so many things
I was wrong about the Zona I was running
about the Zona I was running about the
zonai this man devoted like two
full-length documentaries to the Zona
and they're not even in the game not
even in the game
uh Chief monkey says he the yell is only
the yell only confirmed dwarf okay I
guess ganondorf's line Mercer not might
not be Ganondorf at all I I'm not too
sure that I'm I cannot really speak
about the the voice acting but yeah I
think so a lot for the for all the super
chats really awesome
uh
so oh that that's also one scene that I
was curious about like there's that
scene where you see Hyrule Castle rising
and you see like a bunch of uh like two
chica people standing on the
in the foreground and there's all these
bricks falling down do you think that's
also like an opening cutscene or like at
the beginning of the game somewhere a
hundred percent because from all the
websites apparently this event at the
start of Tis the Kingdom is called the
upheaval the uh that seems to be the new
name for whatever this is we have the
Calamity now we've got the upheaval yeah
oh send me a link in Discord to the site
and stuff because I haven't seen the
information yeah no worries I'll send it
um I reckon yeah this is towards the
start of the game just after
uh no because we see Hyrule Castle
rising at the same time the the bricks
are falling don't we I'm not I'm not
sure about that it's already floating
replacing yeah if you go to the first
shot I think the camera might just be
moving up and it looks like
you think yeah I don't know if it's
actually well I'm not sure it could very
well be it's hard to tell yeah yeah it
might just be the camera moving
um very well be the the camera although
you do see some debris falling down from
the castle but still this this cutscene
here doesn't have to be directly
but like chronologically it's not like
right after this one
this could be just uh like moments later
after the Castle's already stopped
moving
and these people are just witnessing it
happen but it does seem like it's
definitely the islands appearing though
isn't it yeah because all these pieces
of debris start falling down which might
also be linked to that uh edit that we
talked about earlier where you see that
beam shooting into the sky that malice
beam
so I think yeah
Ganondorf might just try to I don't know
like
uh conjure up these islands or call them
out because someone also mentioned like
it looks like he's breaking highly as
barrier
the cloud barrier yeah seems to be
what's happened yeah because the dragons
are good evidence that that still exists
by the time of breath of the wild and
not only that it exists kind of in Canon
but also it's something that developers
were thinking of as well
uh it seems to be where the dragons
disappear to and appear from in breath
of the wild and that yeah this malice
beam hits an arbitrary point in the sky
and it explodes outwards yes
and it looks like it's hitting like a
ceiling or something yeah exactly like
again this shot is clearly not the same
it might
have something to do with it where this
will keep Rising
but it's clear that this is in that that
you can see those pillars and stuff it's
it's in the underground and then like a
quick edit
this happens
so I guess
it's definitely a cut you're right it
does hit just hit like an arbitrary I
mean it could be after he does that you
know transformation into a demise like
character oh yeah that's true after he
like maybe because then he he has the
power to do that yeah that's true yeah
if he's outside then you know that would
make sense yeah
totally yeah and like Celtic says it
just hits like an empty space it doesn't
hit like an island or anything else so
he really just
seems to break through the the
cloudberry which we know still exists
because the the the dragons also use
like portals
in in breath of the wild so it there's
nothing that indicates that there's the
the the barrier doesn't exist anymore
like it's gonna be crazy well also
um this all this might explain because
because
um
it
I I uh mentioned before how like maybe
the streams of malice were like latching
onto islands and bring them down so
maybe he opens the sky and then these
islands are pulled down from the realm
yes yeah
um those are the ones that we talked
about before like the yeah people
initially thought they were waterfalls
but yeah but they don't but they don't
look we see waterfall waterfalls don't
work that way they they would like
vaporize after a while and we see that
in tears the kingdom they yeah the
waterfalls disappear pretty quickly yeah
during the gameplay demonstration yeah
it'll be amazing if like when we we
finally play and we're like oh yeah
there's this whole realm that didn't
show off cool
I I still I still am hoping for like a
Sky Realm so
that might be I mean
it's a bit it's a bit out there though
yeah I think that my prediction video or
my prediction on Twitter was like we'll
we're gonna see link we're gonna see Sky
Islands
yeah yeah that was all just such a
stretch I followed up by saying I'm a
prophet
but yeah look at these you can clearly
see that they connect all the way from
the surface to the islands and they are
not waterfalls because some connect
Islands to other Islands though not just
the surface you see that one on the left
that stops on another Island
yeah this one here
or uh you mean this one the thick one uh
yeah that one yeah you see it stops on
an island and it's clearer especially
clear in the
February trailer when you see him on the
Flying Machine they're uh if we're
assuming they're kind of malice strings
there are ones that connect Islands to
other Islands rather than Islands to the
ground which is
kind of what you'd assume if it was
Ganondorf pulling them down
yeah
and again so basically I don't know
basically I have no idea what they are
that's what I'm saying let's see tears
the kingdom gameplay
because in that one he gets knocked off
the island and you and you can see oh by
the way that's uh the animation I was
talking about before where when he's
underground uh underground underwater
he like flings his arms in that same way
yeah there's clearly a new animation for
underwater
which yeah a few people have pointed it
out but the Ascend ability lights up
when he's under the surface of the water
which yeah kind of means we'll be using
it underwater at some point whether or
not that means we'll be able to swim
underwater freely and explore we don't
know but there's definitely something
going on with water but here you can see
the the waterfalls just stop
oh yeah they just vaporize like not even
that far from the island it already
evaporates so this cannot be the same
thing as these streamers here well it
looks completely different as well
originally by the way has anyone been
able to find out which area this is
because this looks like the dam
yeah it's sora's domain you can um you
can see waterfalls
yeah is it this is that yes someone
someone mentioned um that one of the
malice things was falling onto the lake
so I think that's the one that they were
talking about in my stream so yeah okay
it might malice might be falling into
the water so this is East Reservoir Lake
and there's like a little island on it
maybe the water's polluted or something
and that's the Zora issue because we
know Death Mountain has the volcano
erupting with malice
yeah Hebrew has that storm so I assume
the other two areas probably have their
own problems they're dealing with
yeah absolutely your router has
sinkholes and ancient temples appearing
from the ground yeah it's not a good
time to be in any region of Hyrule
really yeah modugas like huge amounts
seem to be leaving the desert yeah true
and might also
they even see what hap what's happened
they're like hey I ain't messing with
this we're moving yeah pretty much yeah
that new figure that new female figure
she does like a Kamehameha and blows up
all those yeah those maldugas which by
the way I do not think is that wait are
those shots connected is that what she's
is she the one fires that beam it looks
like we're pretty sure you can see that
the walls that uh she's standing there
seem to line up yeah I need to see that
because I wasn't sure I was like what
where's who's firing that
I felt so bad for the bulldogan you just
see them flying up I'm like no my babies
where is that part uh let me quickly get
this towards the end I'm pretty sure oh
it is towards the end I thought I
skipped it before
uh wait let me pull it out
no no I don't think it's have to clear
up oh
about three minutes in three minutes
five seconds ish somewhere around there
yeah play from here
oh there yeah yeah
here uh so yeah go from here go from
here these are these what same walls
that we see on the great new great
Plateau quote unquote where the walls
are different now so for some reason
time travel I don't know I'll get to a
couple of super chats in a moment by the
way uh
but I think I think this is the past
what we're seeing here because this
figure looks a little bit like Zelda but
it's not Zelda she's got long hair her
skin tones darker but she wears the same
let's just call them tears of the
Kingdom I don't know what you two have
been calling them throughout the stream
but she wears the strip the the same
tier that Zelda has green eyes green
eyes the skin tone and uh hair also
resemble the ancient Princess and the
tapestry yeah
yeah uh yeah they do yes that's that's
the first character I thought of when I
saw this like yeah again completely
right yeah so and again it makes me
think like are the
we don't we really don't know any much
about the legend 10 000 years ago so are
we gonna find out more about it are some
details or some details you know left
out and also maybe we will actually you
know that shot where you thought it was
the
um uh pass Cuts you know let's say just
fighting Ganondorf are those the
champions of the tapestry
a long time ago I I think the tapestry
from or do you mean the tapestry the new
one or the old one from ten thousand the
old Empire the 10 000 years ago one I
think that's just a completely unrelated
battle because they they won that one
pretty I agree I agree with that I think
that was already here is older than that
yeah because Calamity Ganon has been
doing its thing for at least a few like
there's been more than one calamity
but this seems to be they say time and
time again in breath of the wild and
right yeah breath of world only explains
two calamities so we can assume there
were more yeah because how else would
they know that there's a cycle of Ten
Thousand Years
if it only happened once and then he was
defeated how could they possibly know
that it's going to happen again 10 000
years later so exactly exactly this is
possible this is say 20 000 years ago
and then yeah 10 000 years after these
events is when the sheikah decided to
take things into their hands and built
the Divine beasts and everything
like monster May says I'm pretty sure
that battle 10 000 years ago went pretty
smoothly like it was in the Guardians
and divine beasts worked as they were
meant to work yeah rather than burning
everything I think this battle that we
see here is probably the one where
Ganondorf gets sealed so we're gonna see
how he got sealed on the ground to begin
with and I guess this is so he becomes
the Calamity how he becomes to Calamity
exactly yeah and I guess this is just an
older incarnation of a princess who had
the ceiling power before like long
before Zelda
yeah because she does indeed have the
same tear so yeah yeah that's an
interesting uh
you can also you can also see when she
the Celtic pointed it out before when
she shoots the Kamehameha beam like you
can see these same walls
yeah exactly well is it that also isn't
this also close to that grassland area
where we saw those molduga heard from
the previous trailer yeah which was that
so it might just think it's the same
thing it wasn't it's a shame though if
it's just a story cutscene thing because
I wanted to like fight herds and molduga
the ultra hand tank well we might still
do that but we'll we'll see uh let me
quickly get to some super chats before
they disappear uh Danny I love how this
feels like a dark sequel of Majora's
Mask ah yeah
it does kind of like it does have a
darker feel to it for sure
uh Zayden dragmire greetings to the
theoretical gentleman
greetings to you too
um Ryan Brooks did anyone else think The
Floating Death Star orb appears to be
filled with water
this would further confirm underwater
exploration is it is it filled with
water
uh I assume this is the this one I
thought it was oh actually it kind of
does
hello look how we can oh yeah it does
look like it look how the shading is
like bluish yeah yeah you can see it on
the right hand side of the of the house
the vending machine
yeah
I still see that so whether that's under
like a surface of water but then we saw
what looked to be inside one of these
big sphere things and it didn't look
like it was underwater there uh earlier
on in the trailer yeah where he turns
that wheel you mean yeah where he turns
the wheel yeah yeah because we have what
we assume that's probably is one of
those spherical things and there's no
water in there I don't know if that
means like there's a film a protective
like water on the outside maybe yeah
well some could be underwater and some
could not if there are multiple ones um
yeah was that earlier in the trailer or
later
uh that was earlier that was
I don't know maybe 30 seconds in or so
let me have a look
also this is so oh God
I don't know what's going on with
Windows nowadays these weird corruption
moments where videos just start spazzing
out
um
I think it might be closer where the
thing Rises it's one minute that one
minute 29-ish somewhere around there oh
because we're almost there then
120 121. so yeah he's totally just gonna
miss like no and she starts glowing if
only he wasn't if only he was taller he
would have made it if he wasn't 1.6
meters tall yeah
don't don't short shame
we're not look look if he was if he was
Conrad he would have saved Zelda let's
just oh yeah yeah yeah for sure
I think it's after this ship right yeah
here's the bubbles thingies which by the
way so this and the anti-gravity or like
slow gravity platforms are so cool yeah
and here the wing uh wing suit
do you see the wingsuit yeah yes yeah
love it I mean that they kind of had to
go with that in a game where you do
skydiving it just makes sense yeah yeah
this this is for sure the same place
yeah this is it and yeah it's not
underwater here yeah definitely inside
that sphere yeah so it might be
different it might be different
um
did you see that will
it's a zonized world yes yes I saw it
finally we got our first one in tears of
the Kingdom which is really funny
the very first Zone I swear yeah that's
that's second and it's not even it's not
even the one that's on like the animal
motifs it's the Labyrinth one which is
slightly different
yeah it's not under water it seems but
it is still a pretty crazy
Place uh Wolfie Muse the new goat race
looks like
the Khajiit from Skyrim did any of you
play Skyrim
no Khajiit has wears if you have coin
oh
you you did
yeah I was played as a
I don't know why I could never every
time I got to the character select I'd
always end up as a Khajiit and I'd
always end up as a thief no matter what
I tried to do
I guess it's just stealth Archer that
was just the only way I could play
Skyrim
I guess it's just uh
in your nature I guess
yeah yeah
have we discussed on stream so far have
we discussed that Zelda's tier seems to
have the symbol for recall on it yeah
yes yeah so what did you two think of
that what did you make of it so we're
gonna be go it's kind of like in um
and you know Ocarina of Time where you
free the sages get the sage medallions
but instead you go to these locations
and like you help side on retrieve the
the tier for like the Zora domain area
because uh later on he has it but in the
shot that Dunn pointed out he doesn't
have it when he's fighting with link so
the whole point might be to accompany
the Champions the different areas to
retrieve the tears and then maybe then
like they you know it's given to them
and I don't know if they'll have a
gameplay effect but maybe it'll just be
a story uh related change and like the
two shots where it looks like it's right
by Hebrew like the flying ship uh well
not that one but the second one with
that boss and you can see the Hebrew
storm in the background uh like uh
son is there
so that's another case where he's in the
approximate location of hebra so you're
probably going to team up with him and
the whole goal is to regain these tiers
and then I guess at the end maybe you
have to get ganondorfs yeah that's the
big question how did he get a tier if
they're you're essentially assembling a
new Sage group or something yeah I'm
quite certain that is what's happening
but still makes you wonder why Ganondorf
has one too yeah and yeah assuming that
Ganondorf wasn't originally meant to
have one because we see riju has the
Gerudo tier so then yeah who did he
steal one off if he stole one or like
what race did that belong to or maybe
maybe the figure maybe the the first
person talking to Zelda or something
that odd figure I don't know but we see
what looks like a tear on the back of
the hand when he puts his hand on
Zelda's shoulder I don't I don't think I
don't think that's it yeah we go back
and check I don't know if that was a
tear though for sure it does it looks
bigger than it yeah but it definitely
looks the same but it does look a lot
larger could also be part of his
bracelet but it does have some sort of
Engraving yeah like it has a glow
obviously but you know the angle is it's
a bit hard to tell and it's also way
bigger than Zelda's necklace thingy
especially considering the perspective
it's pretty huge wouldn't the one on
ganondorf's Crown be bigger at least
bigger than the ones Zelda wears is a
necklace because that that's quite small
and well I was about to say like before
we we mentioned how maybe like each one
is actually related to the ability since
recall is on the one that Zelda's
holding but then like you think
ganondorfs would have a symbol on it as
well
and the other ones but they don't seem
to have they don't seem to have any
symbols
um well the one from Ganondorf there's a
lot of light in the way yeah so it's
hard to tell yeah there does seem to be
something on it to be fair like you can
you can see uh
right so maybe there is a symbol or
something this one does seem to have a
similar too I think there is but we
can't make it oh you know oh you know
what I was like in the Past trailer I
had noticed I'm like huh ganondorf's gem
on his forehead looks a bit cracked that
wasn't a crack that was the symbol yeah
when it was it when it wasn't a tear it
was just a regular gem I noticed it was
like huh those look like indents is like
it cracked for some reason no it was an
engraving it was a symbol
well I mean it could be that he did
steal this one off the other figure
which might be the one who also sealed
Ganondorf because he has the same
bracelet that link has right and is big
enough to be that fake because the hand
in the 2019 uh teaser is huge
and this figure is like I don't know
like twice Zelda's size
so yeah it wouldn't matter himself is
always like at least seven foot tall or
whatever isn't he so yeah I think maybe
there is a size disparity with some of
the tears I don't know
yeah but since that hand and and ganon's
corpse share connection could be that
the tier originates from them from that
go very well be the case from goat man
uh yeah also hero thank you uh is this
Zelda's mother maybe or the one uh we
talked about before uh I don't think so
seems like it's way way longer ago
we've seen Zelda's mom she well sort of
in age of
Calamity yeah the exact same result she
has the same clothes as though yeah I
think they are like from the same time
period like in general these new
clothing types that we keep seeing with
the earrings like the Lotus earrings and
it seems they also have like similar
bracelets and it seems like just to be a
fashion thing where
these people all wear similar clothing
uh
like this Sky tribe I guess uh tungsten
tarkas says my theory of who the
dark-skinned woman maybe is that Zelda
goes through a transformation because of
the tear
and has highly manifesting in her body I
personally don't think that's the case
but I I know Celtic did
contemplate that option right that you
thought like Zelda's
like gonna change this was kind of back
when I thought the the figure on the
mural could be hylia but uh not so sure
on that now
um I still think there's a definite
theme of reconnecting with the past in
tears of the Kingdom uh yeah especially
now with these tears and we're assuming
we're going to get a kind of set of
ancient Sages
um so there's definitely a theme of
returning to the Past
maybe we'll see something with Zelda
Awakening her powers as highly a further
than she did in breath of the wild but
it's it's hard to tell now I'm not sure
yeah I mean from what I can tell at
least my personal Theory right now is
that there used to be an ancient group
of sages
uh made up of all kinds of different
races uh among them is also this person
whether it's a previous incarnation of
Zelda or like some sort of zonai
princess who
had the ceiling power for a while but uh
like like I said before in that other
shot uh you can see a Rito
uh Talon actually you're the one who
pointed that out to me uh zeltic
uh so yeah in the shot behind the uh the
new figure the goat figure yeah like
here you can clearly see that's a Talon
of uh that this is a Rito standing here
so yes which is exactly the same place
that we see uh I always forget his name
is it is it too Lin the uh chulin the uh
the son of Tabor yeah yeah that's
exactly where he keeps his tear in in
the later shot with a side on on his leg
Yeah on his on his leg Yeah so there
used to be this ancient group of sages
they were successful at defeating
Ganondorf seal them away uh and I guess
there's a Gerudo there on the right you
can see what looks like a scimiter yes
yeah yeah actually now that you that you
said yeah that that is totally sometimes
it's just straight is that the Great
Eagle bow I think it is on the left
this one here no yeah on the left yeah
that's ravali's bow I think isn't it the
Great Eagle but unless it's one of the
slightly weaker ones like no that's just
this one is way more though or something
yeah the swallow bow is not as ornate as
this one I think you're actually totally
right this is this is 100. that is just
straight up the Great Eagle bow which is
interesting because that's like
thus ravali's weapon that's awesome if
that's like not anymore
[Laughter]
as if this was like used by someone
before ravali or something that would
have been awesome because it doesn't
have the blue Sash on it that it does
when ravali uses it what if the link
does it also explains why this weird
mystical power is still being passed on
to like the rook's protection and uh
ravali's Gale and the lightning and all
that stuff like even though the
Champions were not really they didn't
play a sage role in breath wild at all
they were just chosen to Pilot the Beast
because they had like a strong
and they were very talented they were
just the most skilled people in Hyrule
at that time but this time it looks like
we will actually see a sort of
connection to these really old this
really old group of sages and
yeah I I think this is just past
cutscene someone's gonna give like
Exposition or something I don't think
they're gonna be memories as in we
collect memories again I think it's just
straight up when you meet this guy for
example you'll just tell you what
happened
yeah I hope it works that way back in
there if you really want to do memories
again yeah go collect these tears okay
yeah
you know what my hat you know what my
personal head Canon is what those T
those tears are actually just the salty
tears of everyone who claimed it would
just be glorified
[Laughter]
yeah uh that's too much damage man
here's something interesting you know in
the shot uh it's about three minutes 13
in uh you see uh two interesting things
actually yeah so the shot of where reju
and sidon are running and you later see
uh Tulin as well
um
you also see a boulder breaker being
swung if you take it to three minutes
13. so we don't know if it is yanobo but
there definitely is a Goron underground
as well uh it only appears for a frame
or two on the very right of the screen
you'll have to go frame by frame but
yeah that clip of
read you inside on and everyone running
underground you can see a boulder
breaker on the right yeah so I think we
talked about this before you uh joined
uh yeah sorry
well and you also see an engraving on it
by the way yeah because because they
only have official artwork for the
artwork for those three I wonder if the
Goron quote-unquote Champion here is
gonna be an entirely new character
yeah he could be whatever that rolling
enemy is yeah yeah exactly I
um I think uh when you're fighting it as
well in the background you can see two
gorons so chill in there so and they're
kind of behind a little fence it looks
like you're in an arena yeah yeah so on
challenges at normal things for them so
this like it kind of looks like fire
Goron is it like rolls or whatever so I
I have a feeling that that fourth CH and
it makes sense because we've already
seen they're trying to have variety here
they have reju sidon which obviously
were the were two of the more favorite
Champions I believe of of the bunch and
then 100 yeah and then we have teba's
son which is oh that's that's different
that's new but we don't see this other
character so I have a feeling this is
going to be a case where again they're
gonna like diversify it a bit and rather
than just having the same Champions
they're just gonna have a new Goron
yeah I think that I think you're right
yeah yeah oh I didn't know people are
pointing out in the chat that
sidon's wearing the king's crown yeah
yeah
I saw that on Twitter posted do you
think he dies I think he either
abdicated or yeah just uh the idea he
could have abdicated yeah yeah I'm sorry
I just like how it's like oh we see uh
teva's son oh is taba dead it's like oh
we see the crown on side on oh is King
durathon dead he hasn't showed up for a
while is Zelda dead wait no did we
didn't we see uh didn't we see King Zora
in the previous trailer or something
um I don't think so didn't we see like a
brief thing of him
maybe I'm thinking of something else
I'm not too sure but yeah he uh he
totally this is 100 because I modeled
this crown for uh for Conrad for
Commonwealth realm once so I oh wow this
this is 100 the same Crown so I guess he
became king finally yeah I know he did
die too because King doryfan took a
guardian laser to the head and just got
a little scratch yeah I doubt he died I
don't think he died naughty and Down the
River he still lives
in the ice right now
yeah this year
oh uh we'll talk about that one in a
moment uh in the meantime thisio says at
two minutes that's not Link's hand
because his was destroyed I think he's
talking about the master sword shot but
that is that is probably just Link's
hand is yeah it's got to be before it
gets burned it just takes place before
it gets burned yeah yeah for sure uh
is like a past cutscene event that we're
shown later on because again I I feel
like it's kind of weird to show this it
feels kind of pointless you think they
would just want to get right into it
like oh yeah we're exploring the
underground oh no what do we find uh oh
Zelda fell down in a pit
yeah they have to give some sort of
explanation how this game ties into they
cannot just start with Link and Zelda
underground and it's just no story setup
no Exposition whatsoever
uh tiger says forget about King Zora
where's Patricia where's Patricia like
every character is speculated
well we don't know how old sand seals
get so maybe it's like uh no no not
Patricia also the the DECA tree is still
here which we know he's gone yeah that
still it's still pretty much confirmed
force is gone yeah Danny says what are
your theories on the rabbit deity dude I
think you mean the uh
probably the goat guy where we call him
goat guy because I I can see why you
call him rabbit because on the mural he
does look a little bit like a rabbit uh
like well we already talked about that
like before he's probably just a sage
one of the one of these Sages
a new species though because there was
not there was no such species in uh in
breath of the Wild
uh Niels asks I love the community great
content guys
uh thank you very much
actually you guys are both planning
something I guess for this for for the
as coverage
yeah
um my plan is do an analysis video uh
like I usually do for trailers the
problem is this is quite a fat trailer I
don't know if you two notice that but oh
geez there's quite a lot to say about
this one so uh yeah yeah I will be
getting an analysis video out but you
know hopefully soon rather than later
but there's there's a lot to cover yeah
I'll also add my usual analysis out
hopefully but you know it'll be out
after Celtics because zeltic works like
a like a madman
and yours are like crazy details
everything that I miss yeah I'll watch
you also be like how the hell did I miss
that for like well what I watched yours
and I'm like I I'm actually I'm amazed
at how quickly you can get out and like
it like is there a gameplay one like it
was really thorough I'm like wow 25
minutes
that's that's what it's always nice
though and I also really like that we've
like where we uh don decided to do this
I think it's already we've brought up so
much stuff and it's like oh yeah I'm
gonna talk about that in my uh in my
video so oh man this kind of stuff
really helps uh like it really helps
yeah just immediately going it and doing
it by yourself you're gonna miss so much
uh stuff whereas if you discuss with
people and even in chat people have
already pointed out stuff that I didn't
even know someone here uh like uh uh
danurism says seeing as age of Calamity
the age of Calamity theme can be heard
and the new Champion seem to play a
larger role do you think they will
retain memories
like I when they awake kind of sages
they may get the memories from the
Ancients actually that's I think he
might mean memories of age of Calamity
because the oh I don't think they will
kind of lean into the age of Calamity
story at all but no they did get pulled
from breath of the wild into age of
Calamity in that game with the whole
terraco thing but I I really really
don't see them going down that route no
with tears of the Kingdom I think it'll
be that and breath of the wild will be a
story in itself and then the point in
the age of Calamity split right at the
very start with terraco is so it can
kind of exist in its little pocket
yeah split I think that's its separate
thing I think it's that's its own little
story and it works great that way
because it doesn't ruin anything it's
its own little self-contained story that
doesn't mess with the continuation of
breath wild at all yeah yeah it was like
I love how they they set it up as like
an alternate split because that way they
can just do what they want and it's like
oh okay yeah it's a little I can't I
wish the trailers hadn't made it seem
like it was going to be an actual great
Calamity story but then it would have
been a Hyrule Warrior game that you lost
which I suppose wouldn't have worked but
I'd have liked a game that you you had
to fight increasingly terrible odds
until you just die at the end I still I
still feel great I I still do feel like
we were kind of misled with it um I know
I know that HMK disagrees
but uh yeah you know yeah I teach their
own I mean they they they well it was so
because it was it was still a fun game
you know it was it was exactly what it
needed to be and uh I mean it's it's an
inoffensive game at the end of the day
that's the the good thing about it it
doesn't mess it gave us it gave us that
soundtrack as well
anything for that soundtrack yeah it's a
great soundtrack speaking of like
soundtrack as if I mentioned how much I
love uh Astor's boss theme
one thing that like
I this isn't like a prediction or
anything because I I don't think it's
gonna happen but there's one thing that
I wish they would like put into this
story it is if like we could see some
older villains come back because that
would still be really cool but I don't
know how they would be able to pull that
off but like the thing about the Zelda
series is an older villain yeah yeah but
he's sort of more like integral to the
actual like he has closer ties together
but um the the thing about the Zelda
series is like so many of the side
villains are actually really good yeah
you know yeah because they can't rely on
like yeah the existing story so for like
malados or Bellum or majority you have
to come up with something cool and
unique and new one that's under one
that's underappreciated that I still
love is Yuga from Link Between Worlds
yeah he's great he's cool he's cool his
boss seems so cool and one of the things
I loved about him is how in some cases
it's revealed like oh plot twist uh I
get enough of peers he's like I was
controlling them all the time but no at
the end you go straight up still has
control over Ganon like he fuses again
and he's like oh no he's still in charge
he's also the closest villain to get the
full Triforce besides Gavin
like he had two pieces yeah he had two
and it was in the same room as the third
it was it was very close very close yeah
uh Jonathan says the anti-gravity bubble
scene shows the malice string super
clear uh
oh yeah those uh strings that connect to
the ground yeah still not sure what they
are but we will see very soon uh game
game over Jesse has a 4K trailer if you
need more detail this is the 4K trailer
I'm playing right now but I'm not I
don't have a 4K screen all right
actually send that my way later on oh
yeah I'll send you the link uh thank you
Conrad uh Conrad upskilled it because he
has
uh topaz laps to his at his disposal
which is the best I I like commercial
commercially available AI up Square
upscale program or whatever you're gonna
call it
but uh let me see because I'm
running behind
I feel like I missed one Super Chat oh
yeah uh from
jw95 Seven tiers seven races and
Ganondorf who also has one tier
does this have something to do with the
seven heroines could be
uh could be meaning the eighth heroine
statue is Ganondorf explaining why the
statue is relocated
I mean
could be
wait what if well no we saw some sort of
Gerudo figure standing besides the goat
man
but I was like what what if Ganondorf
was initially chosen to be one of the
sages or one of the champions of that
time and he betrayed the other ones
uh
and plus to be fair just because we see
seven orbs on that mural
doesn't mean that there's only seven of
them could be that there's an eighth one
that people didn't know about or
you know
or maybe above that there are those two
that like aren't mirroring each other
but they're sort of like the oroborus oh
yeah yeah that one too we didn't we
didn't see much of that in this trailer
like the orobora stuff
that part of it
still not sure what it means do we see
any of it do we even see the the two
dragons where their heads meet on I'm
not sure if we did no I don't think so
hmm still not still complete which is a
good thing I'm I'm glad they didn't show
that
I do want that part of the story to
remain invisible for now yeah I mean
it's it's difficult to tell now before
we have the game in our hands but I
think
I think this did a better job of keeping
the story
secret but still exciting as as opposed
to the switch presentation 2017 trailer
which was a really cool trailer but it
did show a lot of the memories so it
kind of felt when you were watching the
memories when you played through the
game for the first time A lot of it was
kind of uh we saw this in this you know
what I mean we'd kind of seen a lot
beforehand yeah and it was quite
inconsequential stuff too it didn't even
yeah because it all happened before the
facts and because yeah when the roof
doesn't like here it comes you you
thought like oh this is gonna be
something yeah yeah and it's just what
it gives you lyrics protection isn't it
yeah it's it's really nothing nothing
special
fires the Divine Beast I can't remember
or is that what it says open up Ganon or
something
when he fires he says open up guys again
oh yeah of course it is yeah
yeah
uh Philip says maybe kilton is related
to the goat guy kind of looks similar I
think Kelton is just a highly from what
I understand he's in the book He's
listed as a Hylian he just wears weird
makeup and and clothing to look like a
monster but
uh Ashton says I agree with zeltic on
all accounts of age of calamity
if Revenge of the Sith could end in
failure and still still work at age of
Calamity definitely could and
still work age of Calamity definitely
could okay yeah yeah
having having Asia Calamity be a story
that doesn't end well I don't know why
they can't do that
yeah I don't know like I mean
I quite like age of calamity's story as
for what it is it's it's fun but um
definitely when they were marketing it
as a story set during the Great Calamity
which is one of like the worst most
horrific times in Zelda history I was
quite excited to see how they handled
that and it was a bit upsetting that
they they didn't basically they weren't
a completely different direction but oh
well yeah oh yeah Sage Sage ryoku
actually said sorry if I butcher any
names by the way I'm terrible with that
uh
isn't there nine tiers instead of seven
uh because there's seven around the
bunny
uh the the rabbit creature
and two in the sun like quote unquote so
yeah that's the oroborus one that uh
will was referring to so there could be
eight or nine of them of these tiers
maybe even more than that we we don't
know for sure but it it's
yeah there's no telling if there's gonna
be more than seven
the fact that Ganondorf has one leads me
to believe that there might be eight of
them uh which I think it would make a
lot of sense yeah which we also talked
about before by the way uh with the
seven heroines how they all supposedly
had like a different skill and one of
them was motion which is very similar to
recall
which reverses motion on objects so
maybe all the others I I forgot what all
the other skills were like one was
flight I think flight endurance uh
though I think one was like kindness or
something yeah gentleness gentleness
well it could be something like a
healing you hug you hug your enemies to
death
yeah it's like Captain Planet uh Matty
heart the the useless one like one has
fire the other has wind and he's like he
has heart he can talk to animals or
something
uh I mean talking to animals would
unironically be sick in tears of the
Kingdom oh for sure if I could talk to
my dog princess or you can talk to a
poner when you're wolf link
yeah
let me see I I did see them before the
skills uh
yeah it was
skill which doesn't mean anything like
what what do you mean by skill
uh but they all each heroine is said to
have had a unique power which are skill
Spirit endurance knowledge flight motion
and gentleness
I think each of these could present one
of these tiers and like motion might be
the one that is like recall is motion
it could well be the case and then like
you said uh was it gentleness or
kindness whatever that one was that's
quite similar to Grace like mifa's Grace
yeah if we read if we read that and it
said Grace we'd be saying the same thing
like what does that mean how is Grace a
power but yeah it could be a healing or
support related power definitely yeah
and uh spirit I mean that couldn't mean
anything moving through objects is kind
of spirit like but the
there there's
I'm pretty sure there are two different
types of powers the ones that are
derived from the tears which is when the
back of his hand starts glowing yellow
with uh and those are also the ones that
have the runes and then there's the
three other ones which are different
like they seem to work in a very zonai
ones definitely yeah those are tied to
the Zone the green magic yeah absolutely
because you can see that spiral of green
energy around his bracelet and his whole
arm starts glowing green when he uses
like fuse or uh the Ascend one too but
with for some reason with endurance it's
different and it has a kanji which we
know now the tiers have their own kanji
as well it seems yeah their own
scribbles or whatever
yeah exactly because it seems that on
the great Plateau equivalent area we'll
get fuse Ultra hand and Ascend pretty
quickly like we got you know magnesis
bomb crayonus and stasis on the plateau
and then I think when we complete this
tutorial section that's when we have a
bit of a story moment with Zelda's tear
of the kingdom and that's when we unlock
recall because
on all the Zelda websites they say he
starts his Adventure in the sky he then
collects a few abilities and then he
descends to the surface so yes it would
make complete sense if recall is the
final thing he gets then he moves to the
surface and then he's got recalls so
he's able to ascend to you know whatever
island he wants or can reach oh yeah
rewinding time on the Fallen blocks yeah
that makes total sense or else he
wouldn't be able to go back once a year
yeah we I think Don you and I were
talking about that a bit with the
gameplay demonstration because that was
because I I was constantly like on the
fence of like when he gets the recall
ability
yeah so like if he gets it he probably
would get it during the like the
tutorial but it'll probably be at like
the very end yeah I think that in the
paraglid there are two things he
probably gets close to the end and in
the beginning that whole island is just
gonna have one of those those dead zones
that the uh great Plateau had as well
where if you fall down it you just zone
out and you get respawned
even though it's not even that far down
to be honest
yeah because I think it'll work the same
way because it's the same with breath of
the wild but a big problem at the start
is how do you new to link to the point
where he can't just go anywhere because
he's got these crazy abilities like he
could make an ultra hand car and ride it
off the edge or whatever you need
something to keep him in the tutorial
section at the start yeah I think
limiting taking away recall until the
very end and like you said taking away
the paraglider again it's probably the
way Lil the way they'll do it
yeah
yeah I'd say so too uh we have
on 216 dizio says
uh
ideas on the three Spirals and Lake
thing bottom right
216.
is that right after right right before
this one
I think you're you probably mean this
shot right
three spirals
and Lake thing bottom right
yeah the lake that's uh this is Zora's
domain
like this is the dam and this is one of
the bridges
not too sure what the other stuff is
uh yeah like like we said earlier it is
interesting that the water is brown or
it doesn't look the same color as the
sea oh yeah you're as pure as you'd
expect Zora's domain water to look so
yeah like how Death Mountain is you know
ruined Zora's domain might have had some
problems as well which is maybe maybe it
has to do with the the malice dropping
into that water
could be like polluting the water yeah
well that is something a lot of people
predicted already like obviously
something's going on with the castle
something is going on with that uh Death
Mountain it only makes sense that all
the other races are also suffering from
some sort of yeah we see the storm
problems to solve yeah yeah uh and these
problems are also probably going to be
tied to these new Champions and and
people that you're going to be Awakening
hell or help to awaken a sages by giving
them These Tears
is fighting with link in that shot on
the floating island so maybe they're up
there trying to deal with the source
that's falling down
that yeah and we see it looks like the
Rito of built Sky ships which I'm not
really sure why they need them because
they've got wings but it does seem that
they're exploring the sky as well yeah I
assume that the Rito probably are the
ones who built that
does it look like a bird
yeah the front looks like a bird the
oars look like feathers and the whole oh
yeah the patterns and everything it's
all kind of ritoy also the the
trampoline that link jumps on is on the
ships yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and
does it which is cool it's so cool do we
see a pattern on that too on these
trampolines uh oh yeah they have talons
on them look like these little bird feet
made chips uh and they're like trying to
deal with this storm I guess well they
might they might just need the ships to
go into the storm without getting blown
around exactly yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah absolutely uh Vig says my theory is
that Ganondorf was chosen as an eighth
heroine or Sage to combat the Calamity
but deceive them all and the Calamity
himself as the Calamity himself or the
Calamity and Ganondorf are pretty much
confirmed to be the same thing or at
least the calamity
comes from his
body
because we see all the malice pouring
out of him even when he's like still
dormant and being sealed away
so I'm not too sure about that
but I mean he could represent the eighth
heroine that that's possible because his
the statue was kind of like secreted
away like oh forget about that guy he he
doesn't yeah his disarmed as well at its
sort you know left on the top of a
mountain somewhere and there's a space
in between the seven heroines where
there could have been an eight one uh
yeah but the heroines are weird because
it doesn't even look like they are now
found where they originally were found
because they all looked like they were
carved out of
a big big big bit of rock yeah they've
got kind of a bit of a cliff behind them
it looks like they've been cut out from
where they originally were seven were
put together in a group in the east of
the grudo desert and then the eighth was
you know
banished
it was well it was
um car it still stuck to the mountain so
they never detached it to move it
probably oh you're right yeah of course
yeah
and it's made from a different type of
rock too it wouldn't yeah exactly that's
the thing as well everybody I'm just not
fit to begin with there so it would have
looked weird like to have one red one
there
that's true and when you and when you
see the sword on the mountain it's still
attached to the Rock there so it was
being carved there as well yeah but it
was never
um I mean it could also be that the
eighth one is that Sage that's like
ceiling Ganondorf the the one where only
the only the hand remains and it's just
one Sage that's been kind of like lost a
Time
so much interesting lore that I have a
feeling won't actually be addressed but
I hope it is I think the heroine stuff
man I have a good feeling about that
I've got a feeling it will I agree well
if it says if they say seven sages on
the grudo text then yeah I hope yeah
yeah yeah
Forgotten Temple I think we'll get
answers for some things like that some
of the Weird Mysteries that clearly a
lot of thought went into putting them in
breath of the wild yeah
it gave us so many Mysteries and we
rarely got we didn't really get answers
for most of it so like in a way because
there wasn't much in breath of the wild
like answers it perfectly sets up tears
of the Kingdom to like solve a ton of
stuff that we've been wondering about
like you're so nice
yes yes yes
oh my gosh is that a sonai charge oh
yeah it's become charged now
I still need to make the I still need to
make that sound bite I haven't made it
yet well you you can apply the old one
now since we have a Zona swirl in the in
the new trailer so
a fused Soul says has it been confirmed
whether or not the building rising in
the desert is the arbitus grounds uh
nothing's pretty much confirmed at this
point but it is close to the obvious
grounds you can see them right here
actually you can see because it it's
like one Archway with two more on the
side
and I think that's that or deposit like
that pillar that sticks out that that
had now has one of those new Shrine
spiral thingies on it and this is the
Oasis
I'm pretty sure that's the Oasis so it's
somewhere in that area but it's not
exactly at the arbitis at least not the
geographical location called arbitus
grounds but it is
somewhere in that area for sure not sure
if it it doesn't look like a giant
Coliseum though it looks more like a one
of those step pyramids
it looks a bit like yeah like the
Pyramid of power sort of thing or um
yeah I'm pretty sure ganon's Tower is uh
gallons Tower in A Link to the Past to
kind of tiered pyramid or that there's
the period obviously there's the central
pyramid in the dark world that oh yeah
absolutely like this it's kind of a
tiered pyramid rather than a smooth one
yeah yeah that that one's also a step
pyramid so
I mean could still be the uh like a
place called the arbitus grounds and
it's just a new version of it or because
it's a new art style because they always
change up locations and
that they will still have the same name
like Lake hylia in Twilight Princess
doesn't look anything like like hylia
from Ocarina of Time
yeah yeah yeah you know so
could be that this place is called the
arborist grounds one once you go into it
but
yeah
we'll we'll we'll see it would be a nice
callback
that's for sure uh definitely especially
if we're dealing with kind of Ganondorf
being sealed and everything enters the
kingdom because obviously the arbiter's
grounds was where Ganondorf was
imprisoned and then attempted to be
executed in Twilight Princess there's a
whole lot of history to do with
Ganondorf there yeah uh Ashton says
final donation of the day I got mad at
age of Calamity so much that I'm
actually writing a full book on links
life from 100 years ago Hyrule
Chronicles Awakening of Colombia
Awakening of the Calamity I wasn't
expecting right I wasn't expecting
writing to be this hard well I cannot
read so I'm pretty sure you can do just
fine with with writing
I always have trouble writing other
people's words
but uh I mean that's an awesome project
to work on especially that is because it
comes from sort of like uh a resentment
against the story of of age of Calamity
so it inspired the anger for that game
inspired you to work on something for
yourself
which I guess is a bit similar to those
people who make their own version of the
timeline because they hate the official
one
create as much head Cannon as you can
it's uh always always great yo says I
know a lot of people think Zelda is in
the sky but in the last shot
the structures on the ground
is on the ground there are no Sky
Islands though yeah you mean that that
very final shot where she's like
standing there uh this one yeah this is
clearly on ground level
so but it is one of those similar
floating platforms that we see earlier
yeah it's exactly the same
design as the platform through the Tower
and the one where link interacts with
that glowing orb in the delay
announcement clip yeah it's definitely
the same thing but like you said it's on
the ground and there's no Sky Islands
visible so I think it's also miss oh no
it does have that alter so maybe this
yes no I yeah but I think it's identical
I was I was checking I think that the
placement of the stone to the dragons is
different on that one compared to the
one zeldazon
you can tell the positioning because the
stones are rectangle shape so you kind
of like the dragons are on either side
yeah I think it's different here you can
see right there yeah yeah yeah yeah no
actually no no I think it is the same at
least design wise because you can see
from the orientation of the altar you
have two here so that would be two more
that are off screen and there's one in
the front of it and you can see that
there's one in front of the the long
Edge then in the one with Zelda there's
one on the same side as the short edge
of the of the rectangular altar look
here you can see the same oh no yeah
actually no you're right there's not one
on the show yeah right now maybe maybe
it's broken off and it's an older
version but like it there there is a bit
of a difference with the placement of
the stuff I I can see that there's just
multiple of these types of Alters
floating up there yeah exactly just with
a similar Style these are where we're
going to interact with ancient sages or
unlock abilities related to the tears
yeah so there'll be multiple also a lot
of those yeah also the um that's true
maybe this is where we get those tiers
but also like there's a waterfall
between the two dragon heads on either
side and in the shot with Zelda you can
see some water flowing between the two
dragon heads so they are supposed to be
the same design it's just there's
probably different platforms everywhere
yeah
um yeah or you know time travel uh Brian
doe says you missed some other some
people's Super Chat I'm sorry it's it's
very hard to keep up once we get done
talking about one Super Chat uh like
there's already like four more
so I'm very sorry if I missed anyone uh
please forgive me
uh
and he closes with it it is demise
well we we already had a whole
conversation about that so it remains to
be seen it remains to be seen if it's
just I'm gonna take this moment I'm
really sorry I'm gonna have to love you
and leave you I'm gonna take this moment
to to shoot off
um oh yeah it's been great talking to
you both about this I could talk about
this for hours and uh yeah thank you to
chat for for tuning in um obviously
stream's not done but uh
you just showed up the very end
I'm definitely leaving now
oh no oh no drama it's like and I love
you it's it's past midnight here I have
to keep my sleeping schedule reasonably
healthy so I'm I'm gonna be dipping very
very soon too so after you leave we
might stick around for like a couple of
minutes and then I'm off too
but uh of course it was great talking to
you yeah thanks for uh for taking your
time to talk to us in general like yeah
I'm sure you have a lot of other stuff
to do so no worries it's been a pleasure
all right uh see you later yep see you
later peace peace bye-bye
okay
so I actually we can have one final
talking point will if you're uh if
you're up for that
and then we're just gonna call it quits
uh did you notice the new land mass or
potential new land mass
in this shot
uh
[Music]
cause
it looks like the ocean is there on the
horizon because it's flat
right and then there's Farren on the
side there
right you mean on the right on the left
is Farren undoubtedly okay but like
that's clearly the backside of farron
the the the the the the part that faces
South
so what's what's that other land mass
doing there on the on the right of the
screen with that other building it looks
like there's just a new landmass there
now yeah I know what you're talking
about it it kind of makes me think of
the um
uh like because it looks too smooth with
edges yeah
so it looks like it's like some sort of
building or something I don't know
but that way I don't know but that would
mean that there's potentially we have
disguise uh the sky portion that's been
added we have the underground new
Dungeons and caves and all that stuff
and now there's also new land masses
like new islands potentially rising from
the ocean or something
like that's that's pretty crazy
well DLC bro
well again I I hope that they are making
changes to the surface which you know
considering in the the desert we have
those sand pits it looks like uh we will
have a good amount of stuff to make it
feel more fresh that was my main concern
yeah but either way from what we've seen
like I'm really excited for the game
yeah same here pretty much all my
worries have been put to rest at this
point because yeah we've got
a very uh big hint that there will be
dungeons exactly there's enough land
mass new land mass to explore the crazy
abilities the tiers indicate that
there's going to be much more Powers
than just the ones that they
demonstrated before that they showed
during the gameplay demonstration so
yeah
I mean for me uh this was exactly what
tears of the Kingdom needed this like
final little push to convince people
that this game is not just gonna be
breath of the wild it's just a shove
shove yeah it pushed us harder than
Zelda pushed link off the cliff in
Skyward Sword
that was still quite mean
[Laughter]
oh man
oh Hyrule gamer says I had to go out for
dinner one hour after the trailer and
that hurt I mean you need to it's more
time to think about it more time to
think about it and process stuff yeah
plus going out for dinner is really nice
too yeah like this discussion that that
uh I had with Don and Ed like it
it's just gonna make the video I work on
a lot better because like if you
immediately go to work on a video You're
Gonna Miss stuff it's really good to
just discuss things and ponder about it
for a while and not your your number one
concern not being oh I have to get a
video out on this right away yeah plus
like missing things is one thing but
making like big mistakes where like not
even like a few hours after you upload
you're like oh God I totally screwed
that up that's not what that is at all
that those are the worst where you're
just totally wrong
because even with the gameplay
demonstration my first thought when I
saw the symbol for weapon fuse was like
oh is that like like something with the
master sword like repairing the master
sword and then later it's like oh no
wait that's totally the the icon for
fusing
uh
but yeah I'm not making any videos today
for sure
I have to
first just chew on it see what what I
want to cover
yeah I'll probably just compile my notes
for today then maybe try to write the
thing tomorrow and then
it'll it'll take a while but that's just
how it is
yeah
well anyway
um I don't know if I still have any
super chats that I forgot
oh I I will I will say though I'm sure
that your battery vial video is going to
age very well oh thanks because because
now we have like where they're just
holding the tears they don't store them
in the vials or anything yeah yeah so
like I'm pretty sure we're gonna go back
to the video and be like wow that age is
like fine wine
well it just never it never made sense
to me why would you need a like it seems
like a waste of polygons to just have
those tears on his body but it it has no
function
because all the powers are coming from
his bracelet why do you need that second
item there unless it does something
completely different
so and of course I'm not even close to
being the first person to point out that
it was probably a battery of some kind
yeah but but you were definitely the
person who like best explained it in a
video
ah thanks I'm happy that I could
contribute because that's the only video
I made about the gameplay demonstration
it's also just like you're really good
with the visuals because you have the
animations and stuff
so it helps better understand like what
you're trying to convey when you talk
about it
yeah
oh Professor Clover says you missed me
uh did you send any
well first of all thank you for joining
really awesome
did you send any questions
oh he also mentions the uh the future
yeah we had we had talked about that it
was funny because like Don even was like
yeah it kind of sounds like that but
again it might just be it might just be
the monogram effect yeah I'm pretty sure
it is because those voices say so many
weird things and it's like weirdly
reversed and
yeah it could it could practically mean
anything at this point
I think the demise reveal is probably my
favorite one in the whole trailer where
I'm like this could have big
implications
on the story
this could be a big game changer for the
story
well it also probably is a great way
because it's trying to represent like
how he's his most powerful ever yeah
he's like you'd assume that demise the
very first before Ganondorf would have
been like the most powerful
just because he was like that that
primitive like evil or whatever yeah he
was a barbaric creature oh so like it
the transformation I think just shows
like I mean the dude has like fiery
malice tendrils for hair like yeah it's
the closest we've gotten it's not his
natural hair because we've seen the
artwork his hair is not that long uh
but he undergo some sort of trans
transformation he grows a horn or horns
he
has like these weird patterns on his
body
it looks to me like some I cannot
believe that's something people were
actually kind of right about because I
was always like nah demise is dead he's
in the master sword or he was like
they say in Skyward Sword like his
spirit is decaying in the master sword I
was like yeah he's just gone it's been
such a long time ago that's the
impression like so it would be kind of
weird to bring him back
yeah it wouldn't make because it goes it
feels like goes against the lore there
but yeah well it is and it it isn't
because his
curse or his malice was passed on so
that still survived in a way uh it's
just that it never took on the shape of
demise ever again it was just other
people in in this case Ganondorf who
just are a result of his curse
just there will always be evil in the
world because of this reincarnating evil
this malice that always finds Champions
to represent it
and Ganondorf just happens to be one of
the more more powerful ones what the
most powerful ones but I mean if he like
connects with his inner demise in this
game that's that that would be pretty
dope
that that gives a whole new spin to that
part of the lore
uh di Pascal says
there's a Discord singing uh discordant
singing all over this trailer do you
think the discordant singing will join
up later to mean something
could be uh could also be connected to
that new language that we keep seeing
but hasn't been translated successfully
yet to my knowledge
I mean there's guesses but
people are not too sure yet could be but
yeah it could be like the
the audible version of like a zonai
language of sorts
because we keep hearing it all over the
place like from the very first trailer
all the way up until now we keep hearing
those weird reverse vocals so I would
assume it plays some it's some sort of
clue to the story or play some sort of
role in the story
what do you think will
hello
yeah I'm still here oh I tuned I tuned
out for a sec no it's fine it's fine
we're gonna wrap up soon anyway but uh
yeah
actually I'm also kind of starting to
nod a little bit Yeah Yeah
actually let's uh let's just
uh keep it at that and just uh
we'll have another call very soon and
we'll I'm sure we will I'm sure we're
gonna be sharing a lot more ideas in the
coming days indeed so yeah yeah we
should all go to bed well at least I do
for you it's still quite early probably
but yeah it's 6 30 almost oh yeah that's
way too early to go to bed
well uh anyway thank you so much for uh
for joining me man
no problem it was a fun talking with you
and Celtic yeah absolutely I'm looking
forward to all the content we're gonna
be producing once we get our hands on
the game oh yeah that's gonna be nuts
I can I can only imagine how much how
many videos we can get out of this game
because it looks to be huge
oh yes good night sorry my fiance is
going to bed uh which I am going to do
as well uh but yeah thanks again for
showing up taking your you know taking
some time out of your day to uh join me
on this one
yeah no problem all right we will talk
soon bye-bye
goodbye
all right so the boys have left
NBC
call me all Chad I'm not too sure if
he's up to up for that right now
but yeah anyway uh thank you all so much
for joining I hope you had a good time
listening to us babbling about this new
trailer
I thought I might as well get this on
stream because we we we've called after
the other trailers in the past where
we're just sharing ideas I was like well
we might as well do it on stream
because there's so many ideas floating
around and you're never gonna you're
never gonna be able to cover everything
in your videos it's just not possible
unless you have like no you take no free
time at all
but yeah
anyway thank you all so much for joining
if there's any super chats I've missed
I'm very very sorry sometimes they will
just disappear after a while
uh
because
you know sometimes you'll talk about one
Super Chat and you start discussing and
then suddenly you're like five it's five
minutes later
but the old ones will disappear at some
point
at least from my streaming program it
does not sure but I hope I got everyone
if not I'm very sorry
yeah thank you Gabriel I will
I hope you're all excited and we're
gonna be talking about this new trailer
a lot in the coming days and weeks so
thank you all so much and bye bye